[Music]
in costly post news oh my sweet pose
submitted by skinny fat man Oh skinny
skinny a mother was arrested from
posting her son's video of school fight
online what the mom do that she trying
to get famous on worldstar seeing I
guess or she's proud of her son hey my
son fights good her son was not involved
in the fight her son recorded the fight
okay and then she took it from her son
and then posted it on social media to
say what just she just put it up no
captions
I don't know what the caption was well
the mother was probably was 17 and then
the kid was so you get arrested for that
what's the worst a lot yeah why cuz it's
like child porn there's this 2008
misdemeanors that did to that per that
forbids people involved in crimes to
post video of those crimes to gain no
right II publicity or the attention of
the public
Wow what's would state that to do what
is it statute to statute okay sorry this
[ __ ] dick has been calling everyone
now see I tried to let go that was like
sitting really kind of just whatever
good in let it go you had to see it
laughing there's three peas in there oh
there's three T's but you said it like
there's seven of them dude no statute no
I know but the way I said it is just
attitude you sister sketch one that's
what she is from you guys already know I
can't read you almost got away with it
until this now you meddling kids statute
and end their statutory manners also at
you and their statues like that are in
fashion and there's pistachios that
you'd statute statutes perfect remember
just like my supposedly huh
how did you suppose it was supposedly
sibling sibling
Sybil siblings poms memories to say
Holmes
okay I'm gonna show you guys the video
moment in Annapolis a min asipi know
minute Annapolis you know that woman in
that mini Annapolis yeah what is it
Minneapolis yeah mini like Minnie Mouse
very best what state is this a law in
Louisiana interesting that's Louise in
the MU post like a video in in trying to
go viral and you get in trouble for that
if it's of a crime and you're posting it
I like that get him yet to get some type
of viral [ __ ] like that the state law l
outlying public distribution of some
types of crime videos ha that's dope I
like that I wonder what types of crime
videos I guess anything you Eagle some
types of crime videos right because you
can't count cuz you catch people in the
act of crimes and then you'll thank God
somebody was there to record that that's
a good point yeah then that should be
submitted to the cops not on your school
what if it was about the cops committing
the crime to watch this is against the
law watching this in Indiana because we
didn't post it and work News Channel oh
my god okay if I go to New Orleans and I
get arrested I mean don't look okay oh
my god that kid knows how to brawl
that's not even fight that's a problem
die dude that was my junior high every
day that makes me I'll call he didn't
really punch him though he just pushed
him with his forearms until he felt I
can't watch it like that that makes me
sad punched him nobody missed he missed
all lucky you didn't grow up in the
fight I'm thinking lucky he missed all
of them Oh David no but you could hear
you could hear can't watch that ah I
can't watch that no no fine he could
have died yeah yeah I've seen like she
like that either everyday
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn you grew up in a bad neighborhood
so what's her punishment does it say
school fights are the best way oh no
because they're they're at an age where
well their size they're not so big where
they could actually seriously hurt that
you know that look like some serious
damage no but he probably you'll
probably get up walk and walk away from
that
cuz when you see like 12 year olds punch
each other then we get beat up first is
like a 20 year old man sake another 20
oh man that's death yeah I guess that
makes sense I guess I've never heard of
a teen killing another demon right but I
don't know very many fight stuff so if
she gets convicted it would carry a
maximum fine of $500 and as long as six
months in prison wow she's not gonna
give that $500 I like her she's getting
a fine make her ass think twice that's
gossip basically she said waiting
nothing yeah about my kids yeah what if
that makes it a more extra lame it's
kind of weird as a parent - you could
watch that and you could watch a kid
slam is headed to a concrete bench and
want to post that and it's your kids age
too so it's like you don't think like oh
that could be my kid oh my gosh she
looks like my cousin I thought yeah like
Isis pretty young mom oh my cousin's
very pretty well that's why I wanted to
know the context cuz what if the what if
the caption was like oh my god can you
believe this happened at my son's school
like why didn't anyone do anything about
this but it says she got her [ __ ] what
she still might yeah it's still yeah
it's still drama like she's still
gossiping right the kids are young
troubling what's the point of posting
that I feel like her you know mental
maturity is still at the kids age oh
this [ __ ] fight always gonna be so
excited to show my friends for the likes
you know when you're 32 you watch that
[ __ ] on YouTube like other thirty two
year olds not post it
you share with your friends ago this is
what happened isn't that crazy you don't
post it and then you film your reactions
to it and talk about I love watching
street fights though men street fights
are not with kids but like adult street
fights oh man dude that's just like
[ __ ] smoking crack if I ever did
crack Oh small confession I only like
and this is a very small little sliver
of videos that I like that I have to do
with fighting when a girl is like like
trash and on dude and and and you could
tell it that that like the dude was
trying to do something to her and they
should just like pounds and that's the
only one I can tolerate I just saw a
video on Twitter yesterday that I
probably watched about a hundred times
it's this really large girl swinging at
this dude what are you doing is she
split oh oh you know like what
somebody's very large I was a large man
and when we fall it's highly okay I
didn't do that woman you mean the one
when she's by the soda machine no this
is like a who was watching it but it was
in New York what you looking downstairs
recording a banana well this one's
[ __ ] funny and she starts swinging at
the dude but it's icy so she slips she's
like three hundred pounds too by the way
and this will end the guy cracks me up
he goes see I told you so I told you not
to and he stops running away a bigger
girl and yeah she's [ __ ] a dude ah
you see sodas next to them yeah a
machine yeah that one's pretty dope
watch videos like that it gives me my
PTSD cuz remember when I was in fifth
grade and I got beat up by a second
grader I got a fight with this one dude
and then I beat his ass the next day his
little sister who towers over both of us
this big-ass black chick comes it just
starts throwing me oh I'm so helpless
now those are one of the times when you
try to act right right and you're just
looking at where the [ __ ] the school
securities
I'll throw the [ __ ] play
I couldn't do anything that's buddy yeah
that Carlos partisan thing must be bad
for you that's cool cuz she's small so I
think it didn't have the same flashbacks
the other chick she was just like brute
strength just tossed me all over the
place gave her great
I wasn't fifth grade me and her brother
are the same size I don't know why the
2nd 2nd grader was not much bigger Wow
like I would tell my little sister like
yeah well what am I gonna do so would
you bring your mom here was my sister
who she actually got tired just like now
just took a break she just got tired you
have beauty your ass for that long it
might have been like 30 seconds maybe
but she was coffee all over the places
you like flinching every time she came
by the hallway no she I think she
actually skipped class cuz the skipped
grades her like the 5th graders don't
have recess with the 2nd graders so when
she popped out of nowhere and they show
that I was second grade and I was like
she said that before she beat you up
I mean second grade yeah like you know
wonder kid you have like illogical
conversations so she was like you beat
up whatever whatever and I'm like who
the [ __ ] are you yeah and it shows like
oh I'm whatever her sister I'm in second
grade
oh my god second you a second day you my
I know where's your driver's license you
got one of those buggies c-class driving
license driving her coach
what if she just got held back six six
times yeah she's supposed to be like a
sixth or seventh grader and don't was a
dude like that in junior named me
shotgun Hassan he got held back three
times that fool was an adult Wow yeah in
junior high he was like he was like an
eighth grade he's like [ __ ] life
1560s ah yeah [ __ ] all the teachers
oh god I thought it was always cool when
when the guys were held back a little
bit so they got to be like older in high
school but this isn't me being a
freshman yeah like oh you got held back
that's so cool and then I could drive
and [ __ ] of course there's no life after
high school right so stupid
[Music]
[Music]